mein großes Problem was mit meiner Frau
dass wir wirklich von Energiekrise
betroffen sind wir haben sonst immer als
Beispiel im Monat ungefähr 15/16.000
Euro an Gas ausgegeben das ist jetzt
explodiert auf 150.000 Euro Strom kommt
genau noch dazu das heißt 50% unseres
Umsatzes macht mittlerweile die Energie
aus und das ist für uns nicht mehr
tragbar so schnell können wir das gar
nicht an Kunden wiedergeben uns wird
absolut nicht untergeholfen als
Familienunternehmen oder kleineres
mittelständisches Unternehmen der
Industrie wird schneller geholfen und
auch unkomplizierter und wir wir werden
unseren Betrieb gegebenenfalls verlieren
nicht weil wir ein Fehler gemacht haben
sondern weil andere ein Fehler gemacht
haben und es ist nicht auszudenken dass
in Deutschland das so weit gekommen ist
dass wir Krisen mit einkalkulieren
müssen und dadurch Halt verlieren
wenn man ihn wenn man ihn führt ich habe
ja auch noch stehen dass sie ja noch
2019 bitte korrigieren sich wenn die
Zahlen falsch sind haben sie noch
monatlich 35.000 für Gas bezahlt jetzt
eine 56000 genau sie haben 2019 weil das
noch mal ein komplettes Jahr war nachher
kam er die Lockdown so wäre schon
Umsatzeinbußen und noch weniger Gas
abgenommen haben aber 18.000 bezahlt
2020 und 21 ist es dann leicht schon
gestiegen da sind wir dann mal bei
35.000 gewesen das bedeutet dass sie
vermutlich jetzt schon Verluste machen
wir machen jetzt Verluste natürlich also
wir machen morgens die Maschinen an und
wissen dass wir kein Geld verdienen
beim Laufen wir haben Versorgungsauftrag
also es ist ja nicht das was oder das
was auch er habe gesagt hat wir können
uns jetzt mal alles Winterschlaf begeben
und irgendwann machen wir weiter das
funktioniert nichts wenn die
Krankenhäuser beliefern wenn sie Ärzte
beliefern wenn Sie aber auch die Hotels
auch im Laufen halten müssen das
funktioniert nicht das ist nicht so
einfach wie sich das immer alle denken
oder Ministerien denken
was würden Sie machen wenn Sie
Wirtschaftsminister werden ja ist für
mich unbegreiflich was da passiert wir
hätten ich meine man wirft uns ja
einiges vor was in den letzten Jahren
falsch gelaufen ist aber was wir gemacht
haben in Krisen sofort gehandelt bei
Corona hat es wenige Tage gedauert wo
wir sofort Stundungen erlaubt haben bei
den Steuern bei den Gewerbesteuern wir
haben 100%ige Kredite gegeben über die
KfW mit Staatsgarantie die haben sofort
ich glaube nach wenigen Tagen die
Soforthilfe ausgezahlt klar gab es ja
immer Probleme hinter mir Rückzahlung so
aber wir haben erstmal sofort Liquidität
er hat doch liquiditätsproben ganz
gesundes Unternehmen ist doch nicht
seine Schuld er ist doch kein bittstell
er will doch gar kein Bittsteller beim
Staat sein er nimmt sein Leben selbst in
die Hand ist nicht abhängig vom Staat
und jetzt kriegt er ein exogenen Schock
fachlich ausgedrückt wo er gar nichts
für kann und deswegen muss der Staat
jetzt eigentlich ganz einfach er muss
gucken wo sind gesunde Unternehmen hier
ist eins helfen und zwar sofort mit
Liquidität und der hat einen Punkt die
Ampel will den großen
zum
01.01.2023 Helfen und den kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen paar Monate später
ist noch völlig offen die schauen in die
Röhre und ich verstehe die
Mittelständler dass sie sagen ich habe
hier die die Schnauze voll
mussten sie sich jetzt schon privat
einschränken also wir haben natürlich
auch privat kriegen wir das genauso zu
spüren wir haben wir haben jetzt den
Kniff gemacht dass wir aus unserer
Wohnung ausgezogen sind ins Wohnmobil
gezogen sind gekündigt haben die Wohnung
und gegebenenfalls zu den
Schwiegereltern wechseln dann für paar
Monate wenn es dann zu kalt wird weil
wir dann uns auch einschränken müssen
und als Unternehmer geht man natürlich
auch voran und sagt wenn meine
Mitarbeiter sich einschränken müssen ja
es gibt immer den den Spruch von
Wolfgang Krupp wenn ein Unternehmens
oder ein guter Unternehmer frisstrocken
Brot wenn es Unternehmen leidet und
genauso leben wir das auch wir haben
unser Gehalt gekürzt als erstes um
erstmal auch bei den anderen nicht
kürzen zu müssen oder Mitarbeiter zu
entlassen das geht aber letztendlich
jetzt nicht mehr weil wir wissen vor
März April passiert dann nichts warum
warum auch immer für mich unverständlich
warum man in der Heizperiode keine
Deckelung schafft und dann wenn man
nicht mehr heizen müssen kriegen die
Haushalte nicht den Deckel was völlig
also ich habe den Verstand bei der
Politik komplett verloren Herr Funke
können Sie das Nachvollziehen in jeder
Weise in jeder Weise und diese Beispiele
bekommt man ja auch sehr wert wenn man
unterwegs ist und mit den Leuten spricht
aus mittelständischen Bereich
wir haben ja grundlegende Fehler gemacht
in der Energiepolitik ich wäre dankbar
wenn man das mal aufarbeitete dann weiß
ich dann kommt das Argument dass uns
nicht zurückgucken lass uns voraus
gucken das führt nur dazu dass ich
identische Fehler die früher gemacht
habe wieder machen insofern ist immer
die Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit
notwendig um Fehler die gemacht werden
jedenfalls dann Venice mal gesagt hat
neue Fehler sind und nicht alte so wir
haben in der Energiepolitik in den
letzten 15 Jahren von mir aus 10 20
Jahren horren und Hut gemacht auch das
was Schach Leute immer gesagt haben man
muss auch sehen dass das jetzt passiert
was meinen Sie ganz konkret was wir
falsch gemacht haben
wir hatten 2001 ich muss jetzt aber ein
bisschen ausholen dann mit der
kernenergiewirtschaft Rot-Grün ein
ausstiegsvertrag gemacht bis 2023 das
waren etwa die Abschreibungsfristen
außer kennen Energie auszusteigen hätten
wir das gemacht hätten wir keine
milliardenentschädigung an die
Kernkraftwerke die wir vom
Verfassungsgericht eingeklagt haben
zahlen müssen damals ist schon versäumt
worden dann auch entschieden in die
erneuerbaren Energien zu gehen bei
Rot-Grün schon das hätte man
gleichzeitig machen müssen dann kam
unter christlich liberei die
Aufkündigung dieses ausstiegsprogramm
mit der kernenergie-wirtschaft
dann zwei Elfers glaube ich habe es
richtig im Kopf
Fukushima ich war der einzige deutsche
offensichtlich der nicht wusste wo
Fukushima liegt ich habe es bis dahin
nicht gewusst und dann schmeißt man den
Hebel rum und hört und jetzt raus
das macht eine Volkswirtschaft
selbstverständlich wenn man nicht
gleichzeitig Alternativen schafft kaputt
eine hocharbeitsteilige energieintensive
Volkswirtschaft kaputt jedes Unternehmen
das so handelt und von heute auf morgen
den Riemen auf eine andere Orgel liegt
macht Pleite genau das ist passiert und
man hätte natürlich einsteigen müssen
dann noch vermehrt als etwa 2001 in
erneuerbare Energien riesige
Investitionen machen müssen
vergleichbar 20er 30er Jahre damals in
Leitung also Infrastruktur sonst hätte
man das auch mit den erneuerbaren
Energien ja nicht geschafft enorme
Kapital freisetzen staatliches und
privates Kapital so das ist wirklich
versäumt worden der Krieg offenbart doch
nur eine katastrophale Energiepolitik
ist nicht wenn man von Ursache und
Wirkung spricht das entsprechende
Verhältnisse
Bart eine unsinnige Energiepolitik die
früher unter Schmidt und Kohl getragen
wurde von drei Grundsätzen Verfügbarkeit
Bezahlbarkeit
Nachhaltigkeit das haben wir damals noch
nicht gesagt sondern
Umweltverträglichkeit so was haben wir
heute wieder Verfügbarkeit es hat immer
Leute die gesagt gegeben die gesagt
haben ihr könnt euch nicht so abhängig
machen von einem einzigen Lieferanten
gibt übrigens auch Leute innerhalb der
Union weil das wird natürlich jetzt die
Frage an Herr Linnemann sein
in allen Parteien gab es Leute die
sagten so geht's nicht und die auch
Sachen selbstverständlich wird sich
Russland bei aller Vertragstreue die man
denen unterstellen kann der Moment
kommen 30 Prozent der Welt verfügbaren
reservengas liegen in Russland die das
als Hebel benutzen um innerorts zwischen
Wohlstand zu schaffen das liegt auf der
Hand wegen Monopolisten macht das nicht
so dumm sind die Leute doch nicht
also von der wusste man wir müssen wie
ist die Fachleute diversifizieren ich
würde mich doch in Sachen Energie zu
Hause nicht mal alleine von meinem
Familienmitglied in 100%ige Abhängigkeit
begeben wenn man wenn es Krach gibt
direkt ja den Haaren hat nein das ist so
töricht und wir haben es gemacht warum
sagen Sie das ohne Verstand die deutsche
Energiepolitik ist ein Energiepolitik
ohne Sinn und Verstand Helene Mann dafür
könnte man jetzt sehr klare Worte dafür
könnte man jetzt natürlich leicht Angela
Merkel und die Union verantwortlich
alleine
vielen Dank
nein es war direkt in die Bresche
eines der Punkte die
wir sollten nicht so lange im
Rückspiegel gucken trotzdem hat er recht
der Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft im Jahre
2011 gar nicht mal der Ausstieg als
solches
sondern dass der Plan fehlte wie wir
einigermaßen einigermaßen autark uns mit
Energie so versorgen können dass der
Standort Deutschland gesichert ist
dieser Plan da reden wir über
Leitungsausbau
oder Schienennetz über über ja
lng-terminals gibt es ein ganz Europa
bei uns nicht und so weiter das war ein
Fehler
aber jetzt müssen wir nach vorne schauen
und jetzt kann ich ihn eins sagen das
ist eine Geschichte das ist da läuft ja
wirklich einem eiskalt den Rücken
hinunter was was wir gerade da gehört
haben von jemanden der das Leben selbst
in die Hand genommen hat und wir können
jetzt gerne noch zwei drei Jahre diese
Unterstützungsleistungen ihm geben
selbst wenn es super liefe mit den
Unterstützungen er bekommt das jetzt
sofort will der Unternehmer eine
Perspektive von uns eine
Planungssicherheit und deswegen muss man
in so einer Notsituation jetzt alles was
man hat an Angebot von Energie
in den Markt werfen alles alles und
jetzt nicht irgendwie auch in der
Notsituation da musst du dann Parteibuch
wegwerfen ist nicht das Parteibuch das
ist das Buch
was vorgestern erschienen wurde aber es
für einen guten Zweck deswegen kann man
das so sagen also ich verdiene nichts
mit nein sie dürfen damit sogar Geld
verdienen so sind
ja das ist richtig aber trotzdem
nee da habe ich eine andere Meinung ich
finde auch Politiker sollten keine
Honorare annehmen wir verdienen gut und
aber das ist ein anderes Thema also
Ausweitung Kernkraft auch diejenigen die
stillgelegt wurden letztes Jahr prüfen
wie viel können wir noch nicht nur
streckbetrieb sondern wirklich so lange
das sind einige Jahre
brauchen wir die noch bis diese
Problematik einigermaßen wieder gelöst
ist lng-terminals dort einige Jahre ich
würde den den die die Pipeline zwischen
Spanien und Frankreich bauen lassen und
zwar schnell viel Licht der schon da mit
den Franzosen reden wir haben Gasfelder
an der Nordsee ich muss jetzt volle
Pulle auf die Agenda weil ansonsten wenn
man in zwei drei Jahren hier noch sitzen
und der Staat hat auch nicht so viel
Geld zur Verfügung haben Sie den
Eindruck dass jemand im Kabinett den
Begriff der Grenzkosten kennt
also eher als CDU-Politiker würde ich
natürlich jetzt sagen nein aber ich weiß
es nicht aber ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass viele wissen was
Grenzkosten sind aber trotzdem habe ich
auch manchmal das Gefühl dass eklig
unterschätzt wird was gerade hier auf
dem Spiel steht wir haben jetzt die
sechste Rezession und ist die erste
Rezession wo auf einmal unser
Geschäftsmodell wirklich in Gefahr ist
unser Geschäftsmodell also das was wir
wovon wir richtig leben wovon wir
unseren Wohlstand ja finanzieren oder zu
verdanken haben
ist dass wir günstige Energie
importieren dass wir vor Produkte
importieren auch Massenprodukte günstig
und hier unsere duale Ausbildung nehmen
unsere Ingenieure und daraus hochwertige
Güter machen und die exportieren und
dieses Geschäftsmodell ist in Gefahr und
ich habe den Eindruck dass der eine oder
andere das so nicht erkennt und wenn sie
am Anfang das Hemd falsch zuknöpfen
kriegen sie es oben nicht mehr zu das
heißt wenn wir jetzt eben nicht helfen
und den anderen Unternehmen dann sind
die Weg der kann ich morgen ein neues
Unternehmen aufmachen Weg sie sind ja
jetzt beide nicht Bundeskanzler aber ich
würde gerne einmal abschließend zu ihrem
Thema sie fragen wem von beiden würden
Sie denn jetzt eher Ihr Unternehmen
anvertrauen wir haben hier zwei sehr
aussagekräftige Plädoyers ist natürlich
schwierig weil haben wir gerade
mitgekriegt beide waren in Regierung die
ja auch dafür gesorgt haben dass wir
momentan so ein Problem haben
Helena mal muss ich einmal recht geben
zur corona-zeiten waren die Hilfen
schneller da es wurde uns als
Unternehmen immer relativ schnell gesagt
wir helfen es wird keiner pleite gehen
es wird keiner seinen Job verlieren und
das würde halt dafür sprechen dass
Helena vielleicht einen kleinen Vorteil
hat auf jeden Fall wobei natürlich die
konservative Meinung von der Funke
natürlich auch nicht verkehrt ist also
ein mischmarsch aus beiden die
cdu-konservativ bisschen konservativer
und so also ich könnte was werden und
Freunde sind halt alten Haudegen der mal
auf den Tisch knallt da bin ich jetzt so
zu jungführung erfunke live erlebt zu
haben glaube ich würde uns dringend gut
tun damit wir wir haben jetzt schon 39%
ja 39 % mehr Insolvenz im letzten Monat
gehabt damit wir das hinkriegen bitte
das Thema danke dass sie es heute
vorgestellt haben
solche Fälle kriegt man ja nicht mehr
schnell geordnet wenn man nicht eines
macht und das hatten wir früher ja auch
über Bürgschaften und ähnliches solche
Instrumente haben wir heute auch noch
mit der Bank zusammen und staatlichen
Mitteln den Weiterbetrieb ermöglichen
ja wäre das ja de facto das nur einmal
um das kein Problem jetzt zu verstehen
ist ja nicht nur die teuren Preise die
wir jetzt haben das versaut mir die
Bücher mit den versauten Büchern gehe
ich zur Bank eben und sage ich brauche
jetzt einen Kredit weil entweder muss
ich liquiditäten schon ausgleichen das
ist dann natürlich schon alle am Stufe
rot oder ich gehe hin und sagt ich
investiere das was man ja auch
eigentlich möchte was der Lindner auch
sagt wir wollen einen Schutzschirm bauen
dahinter soll gearbeitet werden aber wie
soll ich denn dahinter arbeiten wenn
meine Bücher so schlecht sind aber ich
sag mal das reicht schon dass dass man
eine schwarze Null hat weil die Banken
jetzt sagen ah unsere Bilanzen sind
jetzt aber auch nicht so richtig gut
da haben wir jetzt gerade nicht so Lust
drauf es gibt keine gesicherten Krediten
die Banken dafür brauchen die
bürgschaftsinstrumente so und jetzt zu
Corona aber selbst wenn die Banken noch
5% drin sind haben sie momentan Angst
oder hatten auch schon damals Angst weil
es knallt bei denen es knallt bei ein
und sie wollen deswegen brauchen Sie
100% Staatsgarantie in solchen Fällen
und wir brauchen das Dr weil wir können
so auch nicht investieren in die Zukunft
und 20 30 Prozent mehr Gas zu sparen wir
sollen ja sparen aber mit welchem